ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักรียันสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนน้องก็
กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนนะคะครูฟ้าแล้วก็ครู
หญิงในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะครูฟ้าในวีดีโอ
ระดับกินเด้อคลาสค่ะอยู่กินได้เอ้อ
โอเคครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคม
เกย์พ.ต.ต.อรุณไงคะ
2565  a คศอะไรคะศ. 4022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวาน
นี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 12 เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพตต
2556  5 ปีคศ
หลวง 022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่ง
นี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 14 เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพศษสหฬ 5  6 ห้าปีคศหลวง 022 ค่ะ
2022 แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูแม่ค้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
17:00 น
พาร์โมงเย็นกี่นาทีคะ
28 นาทีค่ะค่ะ 17:00 น 28 นาทีก็เป็น
เวลา
ไม่ใช่กลางวัน
ก็คือก็
ไม่ใช่กลางคืน
จะเป็นกลางวันอยู่ไหมเครื่องเป็นกลางวัน
นะคะไม่เป็นยังมีพระอาทิตย์เนาะเป็นเวลา
กลางวันน้องแต่ว่าเป็นกลางวันที่กำลังจะ
เปลี่ยนกลางคืนหรอเราบอกว่าเป็นเวลาเย็น
แล้วเป็นตอนเย็นนะคะตอนเย็นแล้วงั้นเพราะ
ว่า 5 โมงแล้วก็เดี๋ยวก็ก็ 6 โมง
สวยพอ 18:00 นอ่ะเนาะ 6 โมง
19:00 น
ถึง 18:00 น 19:00 นเวลาเราดูที่ท้องฟ้า
มากมันก็จะเป็นสี
[เพลง]
เปลี่ยนเวลาใช่มั้ยครูฟ้าท้องฟ้าคุยอีก
อันไหนคะมีรูปท้องฟ้าด้วยนะกูฟ้า
เนื้อหาไปดูที่ท้องฟ้าในแล้วตรงนี้แล้ว
เรียกว่าท้องฟ้าท้องฟ้าสีอะไรคะในรูปนี้
หลงฟ้าสีฟ้าค่ะปลาสีฟ้าและสีฟ้าท้องฟ้าสี
ฟ้าครูฟ้า
ไม่เหมือนกันเลยท้องฝาสีฟ้าคือปลานะคะใช่
แต่พอ 18:00 น 19:00 นเนี่ยเปลี่ยนปุ๊บ
มันก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็น
ท่ามกลางคืนน้องเป็นเวลากลางคืนเวลากลาง
คืนท้องฟ้าเนี่ยสีฟ้าไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะท้อง
ฟ้าไม่ใช่สีฟ้า
เรียนศรีค่ะคือผู้หญิงแล้วถ้าเป็นเวลา
กลางคืนเขาโทรหากลางเกินของฟ้าสีอะไรคะสี
ดำไหมลูกฟ้าสีดำ
จ้า
ถ้าอย่างงั้นน่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเลยนะคะยังรัก
ท้องฟ้าเวลาท้องฟ้าสีฟ้าก็ไม่ใช่เวลากลาง
คืนไม่ใช่ท้องฟ้าสีฟ้าเต้นเวลากลางวัน
อะไรกลางวันเหรอ
กลางวันแล้วเวลาเรามาดูท้องฟ้านะคะดูที่
ท้องฟ้าเนี่ยเวลากลางวันกับกลางคืนเหมือน
กันไหมคะครูฟ้า
รางวัลกับกลางคืนไม่เหมือนกันค่ะดูหญิง
ใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าครูฟ้าก็บอกแล้วว่าท้อง
ฟ้าตอนกลางวันสีฟ้าท้องฟ้าตอนกลางคืน
ไฟกลางคืนสีดำนะก็ไม่เหมือนกันแล้วเวลา
ครูฟ้ามาได้ยินขึ้นอีกอันใช่ไหมคะครูหญิง
ชายค่ะครูฟ้า
จอดไม่เหมือนกันนะครูฟ้าไม่เหมือนกันค่ะ
ครูหญิงท้องฟ้าตีนกลางวันกับตอนกลางคืน
ไม่เหมือนกันค่ะแล้วเวลาครูฟ้าว่าเนี่ยดู
ท้องฟ้าท้องฟ้าตอนกลางวันนะคะตอนกลางวัน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าเห็นอะไรบ้างมีอะไรอยู่บนท้อง
ฟ้าอยู่บนท้องฟ้าตอนกลางวันกลางวันสองวัน
ลูก
ว่าอ่าวาดรูปได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิง Share
screen นะคะ
อันนี้อะไรเพลงขอโทษสัตว์ขอเคลียร์ก่อนนะ
คะอ่ะอ่ะอันนี้เนี่ยเราจะเป็นท้องฟ้าตอน
กลางวันนะเวลาเรามองท้องฟ้าตอนกลางวัน
เนี่ยบนฟ้ามีอะไรบ้าง
มีนี่เลย
มีอะไรคะครูฟ้าอ่ะ
โอ้โหสีแดงด้วย
ถ้านักเรียนรู้มั้ยฮะอะไรใครคะครูฟ้า
ดวงอาทิตย์ค่ะอ๋อตอนท้องฝากบนท้องฟ้าตอน
กลางวันเนี่ยมีดวงอาทิตย์มีดวงอาทิตย์กี่
ดวงคะครูฟ้าที่ดวงอาทิตย์
1 ดวง
หนึ่งดวงนี้ค่ะพี่ก็ไม่รู้นะ
ถ้าครูฟ้านักเรียนรู้กูฟ้าไม่เข้าใจ
เข้าใจนี่ดวงอาทิตย์จะเหมือนกันนะคะมีดวง
อาทิตย์ 1 ดวงแล้วตอนกลางวันก็สีเหลือง
เหรอคะด้วยแดงด้วยค่ะแดงเหลืองแดงๆ
จริงๆคนไทยบอกว่าดวงอาทิตย์เนี่ยสีแดงสวย
นะที่หัวฟ้าว่าเนี่ยสีแดงเนาะแล้วตอนกลาง
วันเนี่ยบนท้องแม่ค้ามีดวงอาทิตย์แล้วครู
ฟ้ามีอะไรอีกคะบนท้องฟ้าตอนกลางวันนี้มี
จอนนี่ 5
มีก้อนแม่
ตอนเม
บนท้องฟ้าเนี่ยมีก้อนเมฆกี่ก้อนคะครูฟ้า
โอ้โหนี่ล่ะอันนี้คือก่อนไว้
มีก้อนเมฆ
เท่าไหร่คะ 3
สามพันก้อนเหรอครูฟ้ารู้ฟ้าดูดูท้องฟ้า
ตอนกลางวันแล้วก็นับเหรอก้อนเมฆ 1  2  3
4 แต่ครูฟ้านับคุณแม่ประเทศไทยนะเทศไทย
ธนรินทร์ยาสามพันก้อนวันเวย์อ๋อมีก้อนเมฆ
แล้วฮะแต่จริงๆเราไม่รู้เนาะก้อนเมฆมี
เยอะๆถ้ามีเยอะๆนะเราบอกน้ำไม่ได้นอนนับ
เนี่ยหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้านับไม่ได้นะคะก้อน
เมฆแล้วตอนกลางวันเนี่ยบนท้องฟ้ามีพระ
อาทิตย์มีดวงอาทิตย์มีก้อนเมฆ
ที่อย่างอื่นอีกไหมคะที่เรามองเห็น
นี่ค่ะผู้หญิง
มีอะไร
แน่รู้แล้วใช่ไหมว่าคืออะไร
เขาแล้วค่ะมีนก
มีนก
นกเนี่ยบินสนามบินอยู่บนท้องฟ้า
ในค่ะนก
ก็มีนกมีนกกี่ตัวคะ
นี่นกเนี่ย
200 ตัวนะคะคุณชอบ 200 ตัวบินอยู่บนฟ้า
นะคะบินอยู่บนฟ้าตอนกลางวันเนี่ยนะคะมี
ดวงอาทิตย์มีก้อนเมฆมีนกแล้วมีอย่างอื่น
อีกไหมบนท้องฟ้า
นี้มี
มี
ฝน
ประเทศไทยนะขอโทษค่ะกดผิดก็คิดคน
ท้องฟ้าอยู่ไหนคะ
ขอโทษค่ะนักเรียนผู้หญิงจะขยับอ่ะโอเคมี
ฝนเนาะมีฝนนักมีฝนที่อยู่บนฟ้าก็ตบสมัยตก
ลงมา
มีฝนเนาะ
อะไรนะคะฟ้าไม่หาใช่ค่ะ
มีฝนแล้วมีดวงอาทิตย์นะคะมีก้อนเมฆมีนกมี
ฝนแล้วมีอะไรอีกไหมคะตอนกลางวันอีกอย่าง
นึงไว้
แล้วผู้หญิงเขาเอาตัวเองออกมาก่อนนะคะ
เขา
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
เรื่องบินไหมค่ะผู้หญิงมีเครื่องบินอยู่
บนฟ้าเสืออยู่บนฟ้าไปตอนกลางวันเนาะ
หมดหรือยังคะตอนกลางวัน
ตอนกลางวันหนูอย่างไรมิหนึ่งอย่างครูฟ้า
อ่ะ
ถ้ามีอะไรอ่ะครูฟ้าบอกว่าตอนกลางวันเนี่ย
บนท้องฟ้าเนี่ยมีฝนนกมีฝนตกลงมาพอฝนตก
เสร็จแล้ว
แล้วก็มีพระอาทิตย์มีดวงอาทิตย์มีอะไร
เนี่ย
อะไรนักเรียนมีอะไรคะนักเรียนเดี๋ยวครู
ฟ้าให้ครูฟ้าว่านให้เสร็จ
สิเขียวมีสีม่วงนะสิป๊าสีน้ำเงินสีเขียว
สีเหลือง
สีส้ม
สีแดง
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
อายรุ้งค่ะบีสายรุ้งมีเนาะแบบนี้นะคะ
เหมือนกันนะคะที่ครูปราวาทนะคะอ่ะ
จะใช้ตัวนี้ตอนกลางวันเนาะหมดแล้วนะท้อง
ฟ้าตอนกลางวันนะคะเคลียร์ไหมคะครูฟ้าดี
อ่ะค่ะผู้หญิง
เกลียดอ่ะทีนี้เรามาดูตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหม
ท้องฟ้าตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยมันจะเป็นสีดำนะคะ
ไม่ใช่สีฟ้า
ท้องฟ้าตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยบนฟ้ามีอะไรบ้างคะ
บนท้องฟ้าตอนกลางคืนแต่มันน่าจะเทสีได้นะ
คะเนี่ย
ได้ไหมเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงลองใส่ที่เป็นอันนี้
ได้ค่ะคือฟ้าโหมมืดเลยดีมากค่ะเก่งมากอ่ะ
ลิกลางคืนน้องท้องฟ้าตอนกลางคืนบนท้องฟ้า
ตอนกลางคืนมีอะไรครูฟ้าบนท้องฟ้าตอนกลาง
คืนมีนี่หักหรือหญิงมีอะไรถ้าไม่ใช่กล้วย
นะคะเนี่ย
โอ้โห
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
ดวงจันทร์น่ะเอาดวงจันทร์นี่สีเหลืองเหรอ
คะ
ดูจันทร์สีเหลือง
นี่แหละดวงจันทร์คู่ฟ้าวาด
อันนี้ดวงจันทร์ไม่ใช่เต็มดวงร้อย
เปอร์เซ็นต์ใช่ไหมให้ห้องจะมีแบบนี้ด้วย
เราเดี๋ยวก็นึงนะคะ
นี่ห่าดวงจันทร์ไหม
อ้าว
หายไปไหนอ่ะ
อะไรคะเนี่ยเป็นผู้ฟ้าคะ
เนี่ยมาแล้วมาแล้วอ่ะดวงจันทร์
ที่อดุลจันทร์แอบใช่ไหม
ลูกโป่งดวงจันทร์งูอันนี้ครูฟ้าบอกว่าดวง
จันทร์
เต็มดวง
รวมผู้ความให้ระบายสีภูเขาว่าสวยๆก็เลย
ไม่ระบายสี
สิ่งอยากระบายสีนะคะ 9
ดวงจันทร์ - วันนี้ไปไหมคะ
สวยเอ้าไม่ลดสี
ดูอยู่อ่ะขึ้นฟ้าเอา 4 กลับมาโอเคนะนี่
ดวงจันทร์เนาะมีดวงจันทร์เต็มดวงแล้วก็
ดวงจันทร์ที่เป็นเสี้ยวนะคะบางคืนเต็มดวง
เนาะบางคืนนะคะไม่เต็มดวงเป็นเสี้ยวแล้ว
บนท้องฟ้าเนี่ยมีดวงจันทร์กี่ดวงคะและตอน
กลางคืนท้องฟ้ามีดวงจันทร์ 1 ดวงค่ะสอบ
หนึ่งดวงน้องแล้วมีดวงจันทร์แล้วเนี่ยตอน
กลางคืนบนท้องฟ้ามีอะไรอีกคะครูฟ้า
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
ดวงดาวค่ะคุณหญิง
มีดวงดาวหรือว่ามีดาวสมัยมีดาว
ดวงดาวค่ะข่าวก็สีเหลืองอ่ะคะฟ้าค่ะดาวสี
เหลืองห่าเหงาแล้วบนฟ้ามีดาวกี่ดวงคะทุก
ฟ้าบนท้องฟ้ามีดาว
1 ล้านดวงตาถ้าวันหนึ่งช่วงมีเอ้อหมอก
มากครูฟ้าเนี่ยเวลากลางคืนนะเวลากลางคืน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าชอบนอนแล้วก็ดูดาวไหมคะ
ไม่ชอบค่ะเอา
มาฟ้า
พี่อะครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะอยู่กรุงเทพฯมาอยู่
กรุงเทพกรุงเทพเนี่ยตอนกลางคืนไม่ท้องฟ้า
ไม่เป็นสีดำน้ำแบบนี้สีดำ
ท้องฟ้ากรุงเทพเนี่ยสีขาวแบบนี้ค่ะสีขาว
มองไม่เห็นดาว
ไม่ดีเลยใช่ไหมถ้าไม่แต่ครูฟ้าอยู่พัทยา
หรือว่าถ้าเราไม่ได้อยู่ที่กรุงเทพสมัย
อยู่ภูเขา
อยู่บนภูเขาหินภูเขาเนี่ยตอนกลางคืนและก็
จะเป็นสีดำมองเห็นดาวบนท้องฟ้าแล้วก็นับ 1
2  3  4  5 บาทถึงหนึ่งล้านดวง
ฟ้าตอนกลางคืนแน่นะคะบนท้องฟ้าเนี่ยมีดวง
จันทร์มีดาวหรือว่ามีดวงดาวมีอะไรอีกไหม
อ่ะตอนกลางคืนน่ะมีค่ะมีอะไรคะหญิงก็มี
เมฆนิดหน่อยนะถ้ามีมีแต่แค่เราอาจจะไม่
ค่อยเห็นมีเมฆนิดหน่อย
มีจ้ามีเมฆนะคะ
หน่อยค่ะมันก็มีอะอะไร
คุณครูฟ้าอีกรู้ไหมอะไรผู้หญิงไม่รู้เลย
ค่ะอะไรสีฟ้าด้วย
อะไรอ่ะอ๋อ
เรื่องไม่ใช่เครื่องบินใช่ไหมคะคือฟ้าไม่
ให้เครื่องบินค่ะผู้หญิงมันคือ
เรียนรู้ไหมคืออะไรนักเรียนบอกรู้แล้ว
อยู่แล้วหรอเป็นเก่งมากนะคะอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เฮลิคอปเตอร์ห่า
เฮลิคอปเตอร์เนี่ยบินตอนกลางคืนหรอบนฟ้า
บินเถาะบินท้องฟ้า Bigbang  1st ฟ้าตอน
กลางคืนเหรอคะให้ฮะอาจจะบินตอนกลางคืน
[เพลง]
เฮลิคอปเตอร์ค่ะ
แล้วหมดหรือยังคะหรือว่ามีอีกไหมตอนกลาง
คืนตอนกลางคืนชื่อเล่น
เอางี้
อะไรอันนี้เนี่ยอาจจะเหมือนเหมือนฝนจะให้
ผู้ฟ้าบอกว่าท้องฟ้าตอนกลางวันเนี่ยมีฝน
มองเห็นไหมคะฝนอาจจะเห็นได้ชัดนะคะ
ผลเนาะแต่ถ้าไม่ใช่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยประเทศ
นักเรียนเนี่ยตอนกลางวันหรือว่าตอนกลาง
คืนเนี่ยบนฟ้าก็อาจจะมีหิมะสบายมีหิมะตก
สมัยตกจากฟ้าหิมะหิมะจะสีขาวนะคะก็มีอีก
หนึ่งอย่างให้ผู้หญิงอะไรคะ
มีนี่อ่ะ
ไม่รู้ไหม
ๆอ่ะ
อะไรอ่ะคะครูฟ้าอีกอยู่ในดวงจันทร์เหรอคะ
อ่ะ
ตัว
อะไรอ่ะกูฟ้า
ไม่อะไร
วิธีทำ
GT  Go  Home ไง
วันนี้ไว้มี 4 อันนี้มันอยู่ในหนัง
ฮอลลีวู๊ด
โอ้โหมาเรียนเอ่อวิธีกำลังปั่นจักรยานจอบ
บ้านเนาะอาจจะเป็นมี UFO อะไรหรือเปล่า
เนาะพี่ก็อยู่บนท้องฟ้าเหมือนกันนะคะสมัย
อันนี้เนาะก็แต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเวลาท้อง
ฟ้าตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมครูฟ้าไม่ไม่ชอบดูดาว
ดูดาวนะคะดาวได้ไหมอาจจะไม่เห็นแล้วก็
สว่างนะคะตั้งแต่นักเรียนเนี่ยชอบดูดาว
ตอนกลางคืนหรือเปล่าไม่รู้แล้วก็ก็
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะวันนี้เราสองคนก็
ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าได้
บางทีสวยดีค่ะอะ